والله لا اطلعك ياما والله لا
اطلعك حاضر والله لا
اطلعك والله
لاطلع يلا
لا
ايدك لا
بجيش لاط من الطرف
الطح
فهمتوا
كيفع واقع
تح امان ام والله حاض يا ويلي نايم والله
ل نطلعك يا اخذ والله ل
نطلعك سل سل راسها من هنا يا شباب يا شباب
حجر حجر
نطلعها عم بس
[__] ارجع شوي
ارذ بالله
الشكو
اصر روح
[موسيقى]
خلصت
خطه خطوه خطوه خطوه يا
رمز بتسلم يا
شباب الله
اكبر طبعا هذا كان كان قاعد صلي كان قاعد
بصلي وتم استهدا البيت كان بصلي وساجد
والبيت سق مطبوق
عليه يا عم يا عمراه يا راحه الثاني شو
الثاني شو حاليا
قاعدين زي ما انتم شايفين انتشروا اطوال
من تحت ركام هذا المنزل مازال عدد كبير من
افراد عائله هذا المنزل تحت الركام طواقم
الدفاع
المدني تقوم باخراج العالقين من تحت
الركام هذا
المنزل